bonjour hélène bonjour pauline à la une
de la presse on en parlait bien sûr
début de ce journal l'adoption hier en
france du pass vaccinale qui pourrait
entrer en vigueur avant la fin de la
semaine d'après le parisien
l'application de la loi va encore être
repoussé de quelques jours car des
députés de l'opposition ont décidé de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel pour
vérifier que le texte respecte bien les
libertés fondamentales
le journal indique que le pass vaccinale
concernera seulement les plus de 16 ans
à le passé ni terre s'appliquant
toujours pour les 12 15 ans et qu'il
sera nécessaire pour accéder aux mêmes
lieux que le pass sanitaires à quelques
exceptions près comme les établissements
de santé à l'image de nombreux pays la
france ressert la vis sur les non
vaccinés mais d'autres vont plus loin
encore hier l'autriche a annoncé que le
vaccin contre le coc vite 19 deviendra
obligatoire pour les plus de 18 ans à
partir du mois deux prochains une
première en europe selon die presse le
gouvernement a toutefois annoncé que
l'absence d'attestation vaccinale ne
sera sanctionnée par une forte amende
qu'à partir de la mi mars pour le coup
son refus de se faire vacciner lui a
coûté sa participation à l'open
d'australie le champion pianiste novak
djokovic a donc quitté le pays il est
arrivé ces dernières je crois à dubaï
après avoir été déboutés une seconde
fois par la justice australienne l
épilogue de ce feuilleton sportivo
politico judiciaire autour de
l'exemption médical et du visa du
tennisman fait toujours la une de la
presse australienne jeu set et vax
d'après de sydney morning herald la
justice a finalement validé la décision
du gouvernement fédéral d'expulser le
joueur aux motifs je cite que son
exemple risquerait d'encourager le
sentiment anti vaccination et de
déclencher une recrudescence des
troubles civils une décision accueillie
avec satisfaction en australie on le
sait le bras de fer engagé par novak
djokovic a ulcéré l'opinion le départ du
serbe titre sans aménité
decourrière mail avec un jeu de mots sur
le terme technique retour de service en
serbie précisément le feuilleton
djokovic a également été suivie de près
par la presse nationale dans l'ensemble
très critique envers les autorités
australiennes à l'image du tabloïde à
l'eau qui dénonce la façon dont le
joueur aurait été traité comme un
criminel en promettant que novak
djokovic le plus grand champion de tous
les temps je cite reviendra encore plus
fort encore meilleur sur les courts de
tennis une revanche dont semble douter
le quotidien français le monde qui
évoque les dégâts pour le joueur en
terme d'image mais aussi sur le plan
sportif puisque novak djokovic nonuple
vainqueur de l'open d'australie ne
pourra pas défendre son trophée et par
ainsi également l'occasion de remporter
un 21e titre de grand chelem le journal
parle de dégâts et de gâchis également
pour le gouvernement construire batteur
de scott morrison a critiqué notamment
par l'opposition travailliste pour sa
gestion jugée pour le moins
approximative de cette affaire sans
parler du gâchis aussi pour les amateurs
de tennis hélène à la une également ce
matin le rapport de l' ong oxfam qui
affirme que la fortune des milliardaires
dans le monde a plus augmenté en dix
neuf mois de pandémie qu'au cours de la
dernière décennie mais l'humanité
précise que les cinq premières fortunes
de france ont quant à elle doubler leur
richesse depuis le début de la pandémie
et possède désormais à elle seule autant
que 40% des français les plus pauvres
avec les 236 milliards supplémentaires
engrangés en 19 mois par les
milliardaires français on pourrait
quadruples et le budget de l'hôpital
public ou distribuer un chèque de 3500
euros à chaque français sur le lg dont
les chiffres provoquent la sidération et
la colère de l'huma les inégalités nous
reste également en france le débat sur
la question de la transmission du
patrimoine et de la fiscalité sur
l'héritage que libération se réjouit de
voir enfin
entrer dans la campagne pour la
présidentielle
puis quelques mots pour terminer de la
défaite que dis-je du choc national du
drame de l'algérie face à la guinée
équatoriale 1 0 à la coupe d'afrique des
nations défaite qui compromet fortement
la qualification pour les huitièmes en
fin de la série d'invincibilité pour les
verts qui n'avaient plus perdu depuis 35
matches dur dur titre liberté algérie
qui regrette que la sélection nationale
n'est pas réussie je cite à produire son
jeu habituel les fennecs n'ont désormais
plus d'autre choix que la victoire pour
leur rencontre jeudi ce sera face aux
éléphants de la côte d'ivoire oui merci
beaucoup hélène à ce propos on va
écouter tout de suite le coach le coach